l'engagement tient parfois à peu de
choses mon invité ne serait peut-être
jamais devenu député sans sa nounou et
sans les gilets jaunes
[Musique]
bonjour Philippe Brun bonjour Alors je
parlais à l'instant de votre nounou je
vous avoue que c'est pas tous les jours
que on parle des nounous des hommes et
des femmes politiques je vous laisse
nous la présenter elle s'appelle Josette
c'est une ancienne marinière elle a
travaillé pendant des années sur les
bateaux sur la Seine elle habite pause
dans l'heure individillages dans
lesquels j'ai grandi et quand elle me
gardait quand j'étais enfant et bien
elle me faisait voir avec mon frère et
ma sœur les questions gouvernement
mercredi après-midi à l'époque les
questions étaient le mercredi après-midi
regardez le JT de 13h de Jean-Pierre
Pernaut après Les Feux de l'Amour
j'étais à 15h les questions gouvernement
à l'époque c'était sur France 3 vous
aviez quel âge à l'époque entre 8 et 10
ans quoi regarder ça vous intéressait
déjà oui bah quand on explique sinon
c'est très compréhensible la politique
il y a plein de choses qu'on comprend
bien on parle des situations des uns et
des autres évidemment un enfant de 8 ans
9 ans on ne comprend pas tout au premier
abord mais elle m'expliquer les choses
et à l'époque je tiens Jean-Louis Debré
était président de l'Assemblée nationale
il était député d'Évreux donc pas très
loin de là où j'habite et donc j'étais
très heureux de regarder ça et j'avais
j'avais très envie de passer de l'autre
côté de la télévision c'est donc votre
nounou qui vous a un peu éveillé à la
politique pendant que vos camarades de
classe collectionnaient les vignettes
Panini joueur de foot vous vous faisiez
quoi alors ça se traduisait comment
cette passion j'ai jamais eu des posters
de politique dans ma chambre
mais c'est vrai que j'étais un gamin un
peu particulier je lisais le monde genre
12 ou 13 ans je m'abonnais à tout un tas
de revues j'étais vraiment passionné par
la politique et finalement meilleur
moment de de dans le monde des meilleurs
moments de mon enfance c'est c'est coupe
du monde de foot et les présidentielles
et qui sont un peu les coupes du monde
donc c'est l'équivalent voilà donc ça
c'est pour votre réveil à la politique
si on s'intéresse plus à votre
engagement politique
éléments déclencheur ça a été d'une
certaine façon les gilets jaunes fin
2018 alors à l'époque vous étiez diplômé
d'acheter tout juste diplômé de l'ENA et
ça peut paraître assez étonnant mais
vous avez décidé de vous rendre sur les
ronds-points pourquoi on est en novembre
2018 et puis je sortais de Léna et on a
une autre classement à peu près à ce
moment-là donc on n'a pas d'affectation
encore je retourne chez mes parents en
Normandie et puis arrive le mouvement
des gilets jaunes c'était le 17 novembre
et là je vois arriver sur les
ronds-points toi d'agent que je connais
des copains qui étaient avec moi au
collège l'école primaire et je vois
finalement tout un tas de gens
absentionnistes militants ou qui votent
d'habitude pour le RN ou pour les
extrêmes et qui finalement se politise
viennent discuter les uns avec les
autres trouvent des solutions et quand
ils se mettent ensemble sur un
rond-point de quoi parle-t-il et bien de
pouvoir d'achat de nouvelles
institutions démocratiques avec le RIC
bah pas d'immigration parle pas
d'insécurité ne parle pas de l'islam et
j'ai vu finalement dans les gilets
jaunes une expérience démocratique
nouvelle que la gauche et on n'a pas
très bien saisi la gauche pendant
longtemps à penser que c'était un
mouvement néo-poujadiste pour vous ça a
été une révélation oui une révélation on
a vu un peuple finalement à l'état brut
qui essayait de de reprendre la main sur
son destin qui essayait de retrouver
finalement le chemin du collectif dans
un pays de se repolitiser d'une se
repolitiser au sens noble du terme et ce
qui s'est passé sur les ronds-points est
une grande leçon pour nous les femmes et
les hommes politiques et doit de mon
point de vue nourrir la refondation de
la gauche dans les années qui viennent
alors sur ces ronds-points vous avez
fait une rencontre déterminante c'est
Ingrid Levavasseur une des figures des
des gilets jaunes on peut dire qu'elle
est un peu à l'origine de votre première
candidature à une élection on le voit
sur cette photo vous avez été tête de
liste au municipale avec elle sur votre
liste à Louviers absolument Ingrid que
je connais bien qui était télé tous les
débuts du mouvement sur le péage de
Bouville qui est aussi dans ma
circonscription et effectivement avec
Ingrid on a monté cette liste aux
municipale vous l'auriez fait sans elle
ou
probablement mais ça aurait pété
totalement différent sans elle c'est une
personnalité très charismatique et
qu'une forte capacité d'entraînement et
qui incarnée un combat absolument
central qui est celui des femmes
monoparentales et puis aussi la question
des soignants elle était soignante
aide-soignante et avec son charisme ça
détermination elle a réussi à donner une
très belle image de ce mouvement qui a
malheureusement été dégradé par les
manifestations parisiennes mais je
distingue finalement les gilets jaunes
des ronds-points dont il faut retenir je
crois beaucoup de choses et les
manifestations parisiennes qui ne
correspondaient pas à l'esprit de ce que
nos jouets moi sur les ronds-points à
Louviers alors ces deux expériences les
gilets jaunes et cette liste aux
municipales vous ont convaincu qu'il
fallait refonder la gauche alors c'est
ambitieux vous auriez pu théoriser cette
refondation en écrivant un livre non
vous vous avez préféré organiser une
fête populaire avec foire à tout baraque
à frites et auto-tamponneuse et au
milieu de tout cela on le voit sur cette
affiche discours de Philippe Brun euh la
refondation de la gauche ça passe par ce
genre d'événements oui absolument c'est
à dire qu'aujourd'hui la politique est
une langue étrangère pour beaucoup de
gens elle est incompréhensible et les
gens qui vont aux réunion politique sont
déjà des gens déjà convaincus dans des
militants
avec un fort capital culturel et de fait
nous faisons de la politique souvent en
chambre sans être près des
préoccupations des gens j'ai décidé
d'organiser un rassemblement politique
que ce soit pas juste des grands
discours évidemment des militants déjà
convaincus mais pour faire venir les
gens bah il y avait effectivement une
foire à tous les foires à tout chez nous
c'est ça veut dire braderie tous un mot
qui n'existe qu'en Normandie il y avait
effectivement des trampolines des
Barbapapa des frites donc à un moment
festif et ça a marché ça a très bien
marché
il y avait mon discours plus de 500
personnes qui ont écouté et puis des
ateliers sur le féminisme des ateliers
sur le monde du travail des ateliers sur
les retraites des ateliers sur la
sécurité et moi pour moi c'est à ça que
je dois servir un événement politique
populaire il y a des gens qui passent
qui viennent pour une raison ou pour une
autre et qui se politissent se rendre
compte que leur colère et bien elles
sont partagées par plein d'autres gens
et que quelque chose se passe dans la
société qu'il faut suivre alors ce qui
résume assez bien aussi votre engagement
c'est ce que on vous avait appelé
l'école de l'engagement que vous avez
créé vous-même avec Arnaud Montebourg
comme parrain de la toute première
promotion ça aussi c'est lié à votre
diagnostic d'une gauche qui s'est un peu
coupée du peuple oui aujourd'hui 80% des
députés sont cadres alors que 80% des
Français ne le sont pas il y a plus que
deux ou trois je crois ouvrier à
l'Assemblée nationale il y en avait 50
dans les années 70 la politique est
devenue une profession réglementée et il
y a tout un tas de gens sur le terrain
qui pourraient parfaitement être député
être parfaitement représenté les autres
donc là l'idée c'est d'avoir des élèves
dans cette école qui soit plus
représentatives de la société française
donc les élèves de cette école sont tous
ouvriers employés des glacières des
aide-soignante
euh opérateur sur une plateforme
téléphonique voilà et ces gens-là ils
ont vocation à nous remplacer moi c'est
ce que je porte très fortement c'est
qu'il y ait finalement à l'Assemblée
nationale au moins 40% d'ouvriers
d'employés moi je porte ce principe de
la parité populaire on a fait la parité
femme homme il faut encore qu'on fasse
des progrès sur ce sujet là il faut
aujourd'hui qu'on est 40 au moins 40 %
d'ouvriers et d'employés à l'Assemblée
nationale est-ce que j'ai remarqué
pendant les gilets jaunes c'est que sur
les ronds-points il y avait des gens qui
s'exprimaient aussi bien que les députés
que vous intervenez et qui était aussi
expert que les gens parfois qu'on entend
dans l'hémicycle et n'ont ces gens-là
moi je préférerais les voir représenter
leur concitoyens et vous leur apprenez
quoi dans cette école alors c'est une
école pour se donner les clés finalement
pour s'engager donc il y a des cours
évidemment théoriques donc vous avez de
la philo de l'histoire voir des outils
de défense intellectuels vous avez du
droit des finances publiques des savoirs
techniques et puis des savoir-faire
politiques comment on monte une
manifestation comment on monte une
pétition comment créer une mobilisation
dans son école dans son usine dans son
entreprise comment on trouver une
campagne électorale car le but à la fin
c'est évidemment d'être élu d'un mot
juste un ouvrier qui serait sympathisant
du rassemblement national il aurait sa
place dans votre école non c'est une
école c'est une école qui n'est pas
partisane mais qui a un socle de valeur
voilà on n'est pas là pour former des
députés RN ou des députés macronistes
mais des gens qui partagent les valeurs
de la gauche c'est quoi de la gauche
c'est juste sociale la reconstruction
écologique et puis de nouvelles
institutions démocratique alors si on
s'intéresse à votre travail à
l'Assemblée à présent il a pris une
forme assez originale avec tout ce que
vous avez fait sur le dossier EDF on
vous a confié une mission vous avez posé
des questions on vous a pas répondu et
donc et ben vous êtes rendu sur place au
ministère de l'économie et des finances
je suis venu avec
l'administratrice de la commission des
finances et nous avons recopié sur des
cahiers les documents qui nous ont été
montrés donc c'est un peu ridicule là on
a les on a très très mal au poignet
jamais je n'aurai eu finalement
communication des documents que j'ai
demandé mais je crois que nous devons
réfléchir collectivement à cet entramme
au liberté constitutionnelle qui a
aujourd'hui été imposé par le
gouvernement et qui est sans précédent
dans l'histoire de notre République
alors ce qui m'intéresse là dedans c'est
pas forcément le fond du dossier c'est
pas vraiment l'objet de notre émission
c'est plutôt votre démarche
ça ressemble presque à une perquisition
c'est assez spectaculaire mais vous
exercez là un des pouvoirs de députés
oui députés ont beaucoup de pouvoir et
souvent les utilisent pas il est vrai
qu'en tant que rapporteur spécial de la
commission des finances c'est l'article
57 de la lol enfin loi du premier août
2001 on a le droit de faire des
contrôles sur PS et sur place et donc
dans le cadre de la question de la
nationalisation d'EDF j'avais demandé
des documents au gouvernement
gouvernement ne voulait pas me les
donner et donc je suis allé à aussi
faire un contrôle sur pièce c’est un
polyclerc en une perquisition et j'ai
découvert effectivement un plan caché du
gouvernement de procéder à nouveau
indémantèlement d'EDF après la montée au
capital donc ça a été utile mais est-ce
que les députés ont vraiment conscience
de tous les pouvoirs qu'ils ont est-ce
qu'ils les exerce pleinement parfois ils
ont peur de les exercer parce que
comment je vais faire et c'est pour ça
je le savoir c'est le pouvoir école de
l'engagement est là pour ça aussi pour
donner le savoir et dire bah en fait
j'ai le droit de faire ça donc je vais
le faire et je sais qu'il y a pas mal de
collègues qui ont vu ce que j'ai fait et
qui désormais ont envie de le faire et
encore une fois c'est pas pour faire du
spectacle si le gouvernement avait rendu
m'avait donné les documents que je
demandais je ne serai pas allé faire
besoin de d'aller sur place et de
recopier tout à la main comme vous
l'avez fait c'est l'heure de notre quiz
alors le principe est assez simple je
vous explique je vais prononcer lire le
début d'une phrase et ce sera à vous de
la compléter vous êtes prêts c'est parti
et ben on y va ce qui m'agace le plus à
l'Assemblée c'est les jeux de rôle
qu'est-ce que vous entendez par là il y
a la politique de bien souvent un
théâtre d'ombre moi je préfère quand on
dit ce qu'on pense et qu'on pense qu'on
dit
la dernière fois que j'ai croisé Bruno
Le Maire
c'était probablement la commission des
finances de l'Assemblée nationale ça
c'est ça se passe bien entre lui et vous
parce que vous l'avez un peu agacé avec
votre démarche sur le dossier EDF oui
bien sûr mais oui ça se passe bien il
est ancien député de l'Eure donc en plus
terrifoires qui sont proches sa
circonscription est basculée dans le
camp du rassemblement national
effectivement il a été très peu
coopératif sur la question de DF mais
j'ai évidemment du respect pour lui
comme pour tous les ministres enfants
quand je regardais les questions au
gouvernement à la télé je pensais que je
pensais que les députés avaient vraiment
de la chance d'être là et vous dire que
d'être député c'est un jour je faisais
dans ma tête je sais pas plan de
carrière j'ai pas fait moi j'avais envie
d'être juste du juge et c'était mon
métier ma passion mais c'est vrai que
j'avais j'avais un peu ce rêve là voilà
et aujourd'hui je suis pas déçu vous
n'êtes pas déçu mais est-ce que il y a
des choses qui vous ont surpris quand
vous arriver à l'assemblée des choses
auxquelles vous ne vous attendiez pas
non ce qui a été vraiment différent ce
qui a changé dans ma vie c'est que
localement le regard des gens un peu
changé avant j'étais un peu l'enfant du
pays qui est sympa qui sont aux
élections on va peut-être mettre un
petit bulletin pour lui mais on croit
pas trop en ses chances d'autres
territoires la gauche et de plus en plus
absente on a la question du
rassemblement national qui dévore vous
êtes le seul député non rassemblement
national dans votre département c'est le
seul député qui n'est pas bon
durablement national et cette victoire
oui elle a donné un nouveau statut à la
gauche dans mon territoire et aux idées
que je représente et c'est ça surtout
qu'il y a qui a changé pour moi très
bien c'est la fin de cette émission
merci beaucoup Philippe Brun d'être venu
dans la politique et moi
[Musique]